there's been a strange phenomenon
sweeping central germany while the true
extent of its influence is still unknown
it seems to have been going on for quite
some time now usually in irregular
intervals if you were to head down to
any of the towns within the affected
region for a visit the chances of you
noticing anything out of the ordinary
would still be rather low but then again
if you're in the wrong place at the
wrong time it's entirely possible you
could witness an occurrence of scp-3023
every arachnophobe's worst nightmare one
terrifying incident happened at a
baseball game held during the height of
the summer with the scorching sun
hanging high above a stadium packed with
eager fans the home team was neck and
neck with their long time rivals from
the next town over as the players took
to the field after a changeover
everything hung in the balance the home
team's coach had made a bold change
sending out a new baseman a young man
named jennick denke he was a rookie
untested but the team's strongest
veterans had been doing their best
through the whole first half of the game
and still the scores were almost tied
and so janak stepped up to the base
unaware that making the next catch would
change his life forever the crowd was
silent the tensions flattening their
cheers and chants to a low murmur as the
rival's heaviest hitter stepped up to
the bat he was a behemoth arms twice the
size of the baseball bat he carried over
his broad shoulder striding up with
confidence as he ready to swing watching
and waiting a bead of sweat rolled down
yannick's forehead dropping down the
bridge of his nose he couldn't tell
which was making him sweat more the heat
of the sun or his own nerves his
teammate at the pitcher's mound lifted a
leg the baseball in hand if he gripped
the ball any tighter his fingernails
might have splintered and got lodged in
the white synthetic leather wrapped
around it yannick stared not even
bothering to wipe away the drops of
sweat in his eyes as his teammate's
throwing arm reeled back and hurled the
ball forward it felt like time itself
had slowed down the rival team's batter
swatted the baseball out of the air with
an earth-shattering crack that sent the
ball speeding through the air yannick
dashed to catch it his mitt outstretched
the ball was craning back down to earth
like a white and red meteorite almost
moving fast enough to burn up on
re-entry as it hurled through the
atmosphere janet could feel his heart
rattling against his ribcage as every
instinct told him he'd never make that
fateful catch in a final act of
desperation he leaped off the ground
with every ounce of strength and all
around him the crowd exploded with the
thunderous sounds of overjoyed applause
the mighty force of the weighty corkball
was like catching a punch in mid-air the
tremors of the impact rippling down
yannick's arm he felt that first before
realizing that the ball was now lodged
securely in his hand he'd done it he'd
made the catch the batter was out but
before he could even react in
celebration it happened his arm
recovered from the initial shock of the
catch just in time to feel the
lightning-fast flurry of small legs
scuttling over his skin barely able to
catch his breath the last thing janek
saw was something that used to be the
baseball hurriedly crawling up his chest
towards his neck from a distance his
teammates the fans in the audience only
saw him drop to the turf flailing his
arms trying to brush off something
crawling over him as it attacked and
killed the young baseman in what
otherwise would have been the proudest
moment of his life while that might have
been the first time anything like that
had ever happened it certainly wouldn't
be the last now have you ever passed by
an abandoned building and felt an urge
to look around inside of course a lot of
us have but most of us are smart enough
to resist the urge but on the very rare
times you and your friends have worked
up the courage to explore somewhere like
this you've probably never found
anything all that interesting then again
you might want to think twice before
sneaking past those keep out and
condemned signs maxi and iva learned
that lesson the hard way when they
gained access to an abandoned office
block maybe they were trying their hand
at making a blair witch project style
amateur found footage movie or they
could have been dabbling in some urban
exploration best case there might have
been a few places of office furniture
left behind by the building's previous
occupants something that the removal
company forgot to take when the place
was cleared out the pair of them could
have just helped themselves after all
they needed a new folding chair for
their apartment and there was one just
sitting there
trembling through her stifled tears
iva's phone was shuttering in her hand
the office had been dark but she was
certain the shadowy shape that had taken
maxie didn't belong to a human being
clamping her hand over her mouth to
silence her terrified breaths she peered
out from under the desk pointing her
phone's camera wherever she looked as it
recorded iva could hear the loud tapping
of several metal legs moving hurriedly
around the empty office the noise would
pause at irregular intervals every time
it stopped she thought no prayed that
the creature was gone but just as iva
went to look she would hear the same
sound quick scampering steps the kind of
movements that feel unnatural to look at
that are only possible for things with
eight legs perhaps that made it worse
the creature didn't shriek or scream or
breathe like you'd expect of some awful
monster in a horror movie but then again
how could it it had been a chair when
maxie had walked up to it nothing more
than an ordinary folding chair the
patter of metal footsteps stopped again
this time for longer it had to be gone
now she thought she gave it another few
seconds just to make sure the silence
wasn't broken again crawling out from
under the desk her phone still in her
hand iva allowed herself to breathe a
tentative sigh only for that side to
become a scream as it lunged at her the
chair's seat and back now the body in
maw of an angry arachnid monster as iva
screamed her phone caught the whole
gruesome sight on camera you might be
starting to see a pattern emerging here
but there's yet another twist in this
multi-legged tale what if these
occurrences weren't just random
incidents sure they might fall into the
freak of nature category like so many
other anomalous incidents but while it's
unclear exactly how these particular
anomalies come about could it be
possible that something or someone is
creating them on purpose mobile task
force alpha 21 were already on the scene
in the aftermath of the latest incursion
the elite foundation strike team had
eliminated the threat luckily it had
started life as a phone meaning they
were able to remotely destroy it causing
its electronic components to detonate
not before it had killed two foundation
personnel though naturally now came the
cleanup operation gathering up evidence
leaving no trace of what had happened
the scp foundation still had little clue
as to what exactly caused instances of
this nature a phenomenon they had now
designated as scp-3023
all they had to go on was a handful of
cases and footage recovered from a cell
phone that had belonged to an urban
explorer who'd met an untimely end at
the jaws of a folding chair but speaking
of footage something unusual had been
caught by a security camera a few days
before the latest scp-3023
incident the security footage showed a
man breaking into an office where the
latest 3023 instance the telephone had
been found as he picked up the phone in
question this individual's jaw appeared
to unnaturally split open horizontally
allowing four dark tongue-like
appendages to emerge these appendages
rubbed the phone for over half a minute
before retracting the man then returned
the phone to its original place and
promptly left the office thanks to
further investigations conducted by the
foundation's forensic experts this
unknown individual was identified as mr
tsar the owner of a local restaurant
naturally mtf alpha 21 moved in to
apprehend the suspect the only real lead
as to what has been causing the multiple
instances of scp-3023
to begin occurring in germany however
when sar was eventually detained he
showed next to no sign of any anomalies
in his body he claimed to have no memory
of the events depicted in the security
footage had never encountered any
previous scp-3023 instance and seemed to
possess no knowledge of the strange
properties he exhibited on camera
nonetheless the scp foundation was
forced to detain mr tsar although he
never displayed any anomalous behavior
ever again now you might be forgiven for
thinking that with sore held in
foundation custody everyone could
breathe a sigh of relief but sadly for
any arachnophobes watching at home new
instances of scp-3023 kept cropping up
an even stranger and more horrific
fashion than ever before imagine you had
a headache and we're talking about a
real killer here one of those power
drill to the frontal lobe migraines
maybe you'd spend too much time glued to
a computer screen at work and all that
blue light from your monitor scrambled
your gray matter or perhaps last night
was a pretty wild one and after a few
too many drinks you were left feeling
hung over the next morning what's your
go-to response in that situation
obviously you can call in sick to work
then go to your medicine cabinet or an
over-the-counter pharmacy then grab some
basic painkillers paracetamol aspirin
ibuprofen all the things that we trust
to make us feel better not to make
things even worse to patrick this
started as one of the most normal things
in the world like you or i his immediate
response to fighting himself suffering
from a raging headache was to grab a
gelatin capsule of ibuprofen as casually
and unsuspectingly as anyone would he
took the pill in hopes of quickly
relieving his pain and carrying on with
his day probably even chasing it down
with a quick glass of water only
unbeknownst and unseen to patrick
something happened the moment that
ibuprofen capsule passed through his
lips and went towards his throat
something that stopped it from fully
going down his throat in fact much like
the baseball the folding chair the phone
and who knows how many other unrecorded
incidents the pill had sprouted eight
spider-like legs at first it started as
a gentle cough like you'd expect when a
capsule gets lodged in your throat
grabbing a tissue patrick gave a few
grunting attempts at clearing his airway
there was definitely something in there
that almost felt like it was scratching
not the kind of scratch at the back of
the throat brought on by some allergies
the kind of scratching that caused
patrick to cough up blood when he put a
tissue to his mouth the kind of
scratching that he could feel moving
crawling around his windpipe
perhaps if he had more time patrick
could have raced to the hospital and had
whatever was clawing its way around his
throat removed safely with that free
european health care unfortunately the
thing that the capsule had turned into
just as he swallowed it wasn't that kind
racked with unimaginable pain patrick
was writhing and spluttering
uncontrollably his mouth filled with
more bile and blood than saliva at that
point the scratching was moving and not
down towards his esophagus towards his
stomach it was going outwards burrowing
through the insides of his neck until it
reached his spinal cord by that time the
little ibuprofen capsule-sized instance
of scp-3023 came crawling out from the
back of his neck patrick was already
dead let's say you were aware of this of
all these strange happenings seemingly
ordinary everyday objects turning into
angry aggressive spiders obviously the
foundation might want to have a little
chat with you about how you came across
such information but for the sake of
argument imagine you did know you might
think the smart idea would be to leave
after all
scp-3023 instances are only known to
occur in a specific region of central
germany neatly situated in the middle of
leipzig and dusseldorf so you might
think that it's time to up sticks and
leave that area maybe even leave germany
altogether just hop in your car and
drive to safety if only it was that easy
a family of four was cruising down the
autobahn in an suv just another car on
the packed highway exhausted after hours
on the road mateo and nina sat quietly
up front making sure they didn't wake
their son and daughter both asleep in
the rear passenger seats the car was
picking up speed about to pass 70 miles
per hour as it gradually carried them
home although it wasn't going to get
them all the way back the screech of
twisting metal woke both sleeping kids
up screaming their parents equally
shocked at the sun noise the car lurched
and buckled like something had collided
with it but this was no ordinary traffic
accident without any rhyme or reason the
front of their suv warped itself into
the distinctive shape of a cephalothorax
while the rear turned into what looked
like an abdomen as the car shifted and
reshaped around them the grinding of
metal as auto parts became huge metal
legs mateo nina and their children were
still trapped inside never to make it
out but the creepy crawly carnage wasn't
just contained inside the car the newly
born arachnid abomination hurdled its
way down the audubon managing to
maintain its speed other drivers swerved
and slammed on their brakes to avoid
hitting the creature they couldn't even
believe was scuttling hurriedly along
the highway unfortunately this led them
to careening into other cars smashing
head first into a pileup that claimed
the lives of 41 people not that the scp
foundation would ever admit it with one
of their facilities only 250 meters away
they were quick to dispatch an airstrike
to deal with the spidery suv once it
became clear that mobile task force
alpha 21 couldn't contain it across the
board anything capable of sprouting four
pairs of spindly legs and crawling
towards you with the intent to kill
tends to rack up quite the body count
but dealing with bodies are some
people's business that was the case for
lucas a newly qualified coroner after
passing years of training he was working
with the local police department
performing autopsies and examining
bodies to help them with their
investigations sure it may not have been
the most glamorous profession but lucas
could sleep soundly knowing that he'd
never get hurt by a dead body a john doe
a body that hadn't yet been identified
had just been brought in after police
had found him on the side of the road
lucas thoroughly washed his hands put on
his gloves and scrubs along with the
rest of the autopsy team he'd sat in on
at least a dozen of these procedures
studied the relevant process and
techniques everything had prepared him
for the job of figuring out how someone
had died but not even the most
experienced medical examiner could be
prepared for what happened next taking
the lead lucas began by making the
primary incision into the cadaver's
chest it always reminded him of a
particular scene in the thing where a
character's stomach opened up and became
a maw of frightening teeth revealing
them to be the titular shape-shifting
alien that thought was quickly shaken
away when suddenly to lucas's surprise
the body lurched violently on the
examining table not everyone expects
dead bodies to be able to move and while
it might be rare it's also not
impossible any number of things can
cause someone's remains to move after
death muscles atrophying or spasming the
body filling up with gas as it breaks
down of course any coroner would expect
these movements to have subsided by the
time someone reaches the autopsy room
caught off guard by the sudden violent
movement lucas stepped away dropping his
scalpel his panting breath warmed his
face beneath his surgical mask as he
stared for a moment waiting to see if
the body moved again certain it would be
still now lucas wrote the spooky
incident off just as a muscle spasm and
leaned over to retrieve his scalpel but
while he was crouching he noticed
something strange it almost looked as if
there were a pair of protrusions poking
out from under the dead man's skin
walking around the other side of the
table lucas found two more similar lumps
at the body's abdomen almost as if
something was inside ready to force its
way out without warning the john doe
suddenly moved again on the examining
table only this time it didn't stop
lucas couldn't believe his eyes the
man's face was still frozen in the same
dead expression but his arms and legs
were thrashing and writhing around as if
he was somehow still alive four extra
limbs suddenly burst from the sides of
the cadaver and the now eight-legged
creature reared itself up leaping
towards a member of the autopsy team it
scuttled and skittered around on its new
appendages while lucas watched in horror
blood-curdling screams filled the
autopsy room as he bolted for the door
lucas raced down the corridor the
coroner dared not looking behind him
while sprinting through the city
mortuary behind him he could hear the
thudding of the spider's multiple limbs
right at his heels out of the corner of
his eyes right on the edge of his
peripheral vision he could see the mass
of legs scuttling towards him maybe he
would get out run all the way to safety
before the spider was upon him but how
can you hope to outrun something with
eight legs when you only have two the
most important thing to remember is that
while any unsuspecting inanimate object
near you might suddenly decide to become
an angry spider the chances of it
happening are very very low but
especially if you happen to be in
central germany those chances are never
zero either now go and check out
scp-2086 man-eating bus and
scp-1562 the carnivorous slide for more
tales of everyday objects that are far
more sinister than they first seem